[Music]
to make a quick video about what does
myself look like when I'm doing the
podcast well firstly it's super super
simple nothing to it at all which is why
I think that it's amazing and that's all
down to the anchor app so basically let
me show you
desk laptop headphones just got these
simple you can be fancy if you've got
air pods and let me bright and basically
that's it so that's one of the most sort
of the big upsides in terms of an
implant actually that's one of the
biggest upsides that's one of the
biggest upsides of using that anchor app
to do the podcast so it's it's just so
simple all you need is your phone which
I'm using now so I can't show you that
and headphones an internet connection
and you can record your podcast episodes
so that's what I think if anyone's
thinking about starting a podcast use
the anchor app super simple so that's my
podcast setup video and yeah that's
about it so it's super simple and just
for I'll show you guys how simple it is
[Music]